each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so Christina Otero from Purdue
University and she's got to talk about
building trust for the wireless mesh
networks thank you very much and thank
you for the invitation I'm very happy to
be here and I have to mention that
initially when you to ask me to give a
talk I wasn't put in a very interesting
position because i have many projects
and very different stages and actually
the mesh one is the one that just
started so i wanted to bring to give you
a flavor of some of the things that my
students and I are doing so you'll see
that there is a mix of several things
and just to motivate the work is that
it's just the ire I was extremely
surprised to see the the evolution of
the wireless networks I'm coming from a
communist country and several years ago
you know you could never see anybody
with a cell phone now what's going on
that is you know it looks like
technologically many people are more
eager to use things over there and one
of the things that the tidy sit here is
just to show the mixture that we had in
terms of the infrastructure versus a
lack of infrastructure very odd hope we
move from we started you know the
celluloid always had a very well built
structure we had the wave of ad hoc
networks is there Wi-Fi or sensor
networks and it looks like now we are
going back to the structure the both
mesh networks and vehicular networks
they do have a particular structure that
characterizes the network the network
and all of them bring different
applications with either more military
oriented or morals you know community
and the with more applications to the
everyday life and one of the things that
we like mesh networks is because they
promised certain things and one of them
is that they provide from provide the
increased coverage wireless says this
problem that you know you're just
limited in how much to what the distance
you can talk with somebody
hopefully the Indian structure will
allow us to have a more robust
communication so there are different
type of services that you can start
thinking about them once you have a more
robust communication and also the
service is supposed to be better this in
terms of bandwidth by taking advantage
of several things including the multiple
radios and one of the things that I like
to point out is that and other people
also notice is that this makes this need
for cooperation just because you have
all these participants that they're
supposed to work together and there are
several things that they can collaborate
in achieving the services now
cooperations brings many benefits but
cooperation also bring some pitfalls and
I am interested in the problem that
starts appearing once you don't have
only on its participants and some of the
behavior that we can see in cooperative
networks are either selfish behavior or
malicious and this can affect both the
the structure of the network but
ultimately they can affect the
availability of the system and just to
make a clarification between selfish and
malicious usually you have some chance
of dealing with selfish because they
still want to get something out of the
system so because they still want to get
something of the system hopefully you
there are some incentive mechanisms that
you can offer them it's much more
difficult to deal with malicious
participants because you know their goal
in life is to make your life miserable
so it's very difficult to achieve
anything in that direction but we have
some hope now another thing that I would
like to mention is that there is nothing
new here in terms of the problem though
mesh networks are not the only network
that are cooperative and they're
released to that I can think about one
hour overlay overlays the other ones are
ad hoc networks and although the
problems are similar we have to deal
with different challenges and things
that create a big difference are the
mobility versus the fixed structure and
another thing is the communication
medium so for example just look at the
overlay
is that you know the even if you will
have the same type of fixed structure
you do have a different communication
medium and it is interesting because of
that to look at what people already did
in this areas and actually tell you some
of the things that my students and I did
in this area keeping in mind that in
spite of these similarities whatever
solutions you have to design you have to
keep in mind that ultimately of
communication is still wireless which
means that you help you still have to
deal with the fact that this is the
communication that is just by nature
less robust you have higher error rates
you have to deal with the environment
environment can affect your
communication abilities also where
you're going to deploy your applications
you have many tall buildings around and
so on besides that even if we are
talking about mesh nettles where you
have the you don't have the energy
constraints the medium itself is a
shared resource and actually when you're
talking about an adversary that can
cause you lots of problems at much lower
level you know even at the mac layer you
all you need is one malicious
participant that actually can prevent
the other people from even getting
access to the channel and last but
definitely not least again the nature of
the need you make it more makes it more
vulnerable both to eavesdropping but
also malicious attacks and I like these
pictures i saw it several years ago i
think if the picture that they used to
attack here 3 11 and i recently saw it
in a low in order episode so it looks
like it feels very popular does it's a
popular antenna so what I want to focus
on today and to show you is some more oh
actually yes I want to to show two of
the problems that we looked at a one I
look at it in the context of a hybrid
network that we're using both cellular
and Wi-Fi ad hoc networks and the other
one I want to show problem it for me at
least it seems very interesting in the
context of overlay and it's an attack
that it's much more subtle very
difficult to detect but it can go a long
way and I think that these things can
will show up in mesh networks to and to
put this you know even broader context I
want to show you some of the projects
that we are doing in my
so I am interested in anything that is
distributed under the extreme Byzantine
we cannot always solve all the problems
but I first like to see what is the
worst case that you will have to deal
with so the first project that actually
just ended then we went through a red
theme that was very successful it looks
at how to build Byzantine resilient
systems that scale to wide area networks
and we were extremely happy because they
told us that this is the first system
that they couldn't break and one of the
things that I think that made a big
difference is the fact that the system
itself accounts for insiders so we
didn't we didn't tell them oh just go
ahead and find some buffer overflow he
said we told them we can tolerate X
number of malicious insiders decide the
servers this is the code do whatever you
want and so it is the nature of of the
the approach that actually I think made
a big difference now the other see
projects the other three projects there
two of them focused on wireless one of
them focus on overlays and the one that
I'm just the most excited about is the
last one which just started then but
hopefully we'll put together some of my
previous work in collaborative
applications with this your environment
or mesh networks so let's get started
with the first thing that I want to talk
about which is this multi hope nature
and the problems that can cause in terms
of security and because of the fact that
in wireless communication really there
is no other way to reach other
participants this creates a big
difference in terms of how do you design
protocols including starting with simple
things like routing and the such a
malicious or selfish attack or selfish
behavior can have an effect both on
allowing other people maybe to obtain
free service or ultimately to affect the
availability of the system now one of
the problems that my students and I look
at started with looking at cellular
networks so they were very excited about
3g services
and people like everything that it has
some type of you know graphic and video
somehow it they can relate better with I
always had a heart problem also as a
student to sell networking because you
couldn't have cool demos so you cannot
to show you know oh but see this graph
is so much better than some somehow
people from graphics they came they show
a cool picture and that made it so what
we what we actually looked at is how can
we actually improve the quality of the
service as the client goes further from
the base station by using ad hoc note
you having able to 11 cards so the idea
is that you know you can get this type
of things by building some type of
routing structure that allows notes to
adapt based on the bandwidth that
they're perceiving that they have and
think that we deal with we wanted a
better throughput we looked at how to
use multiple channels or if we'll have
them how that will improve we looked at
interference and how that will affect
when we make our decision of where to
how to select the apparent in the tree
structure and we also look at what will
be the overhead of maintaining such a
tree just because again if these are
controlled messages so the less you send
of them the better and one of the things
that we came up with we show that
previous approaches that were just have
a very greedy and aggressive nature
actually we're not performing as well as
expected so we came up with the idea of
maintaining or and using this spanning
tree and one of the big issues here
where how can you do how can you build
such a 3 such that you do not pay a lot
of costs in terms of overhead messages
and also because for example you know
one very trivial where you can do it
when you want to add one more flow and
download from the base station one thing
you can do is you say ok you know every
time I'm adding a slow i'm going to
contact the base station and everybody
is going to adjust and within the tree
but that means lots of messages which if
it puts it close to flooding then
why we do not just do flooding so we
wanted to do better than that and one of
the things that we came up with actually
this is what my students came up with
one of them really likes trees and
really likes all kinds of trees so he
saw that the apology streets will be a
very good match for this particular
problem because what topology trees
allowed us is actually to map this
routing tree into operations on a
topology tree that put us in terms of
messages going from linear to
logarithmic bond so we again we spend a
lot of time getting this working and
designing how these operations will be
perform and proving that we can get this
this log n and you know have also
examples of how would you even for
example add or delay or order decouple
somebody from the network how the
translation will be in these operations
and when we got all this and we were
very happy we had one more things that
we thought that we had to deal with
which was how accurate the trees because
the moment again this is based on
probing so the more the more frequently
do the sampling and this refresh rate
defines the sampling the more often you
do it the more accurate the tree is but
at the same time you have a higher cost
going on in the network so we also
looked at what will be in this context
what will be a refresh rate that will
behave relatively well did some
simulations also look at the the
throughput we did some simulations so
i'm just showing this to motivate how do
we infineon we come up to the security
but we were at least we could show that
we are doing much better than if you
have only base station and with the
green for example it's the optimum so we
were relatively happy about the results
we looked also with multiple flows and
how we have multiple source how many of
them we can sustain how the multiple
channels will help with that and once we
did all this work we said oh and now
let's think about security and that's
not the right way to do it because you
actually have to go back and look at
other things to change some many of
think that you're ready did so there are
things about this particular application
that actually helped us in dealing with
security and what I want to point out is
that on one side if you look at the
particular cellular model you start with
the model in which the base station is
not only the one that provides the
service but it's a central point of
trust and it allows you to build other
services even something simple like in
authentication and secure communication
the moment you throw-in in all these
participants of this ad hoc note you
completely change the trust model and
that's what creates the big difference
on how would you how would you
accommodate or to what degree you can
prevent against such notes assuming that
they have either malicious or selfish
behavior and think that for example of
our negative is you know relying on
honesty it's not always going to work I
have a have a professor when I was a
student that hoping that he had the same
theory about internet internet is like
communism is supposed to you know it's
going to be free and fair for everybody
but somebody's going to do the work so
in the end is not going to work you
cannot you cannot have a you cannot have
this working without some economic model
and the same thing here you cannot
assume that everybody always going to be
correct and if they're not going to take
advantage of the system so looking at
the honesty if you really realize that
nodes are always going to report correct
performance to their base stations and
they're not going to try to abuse the
system I think that you have a very
optimistic view of the world so things
that can go wrong it's you know either
freeloading with this is the best case
actually but all you can also have
people abusing the system in the sense
that just creating denial of service by
issuing many requests and this is always
an issue with distributed systems on now
another thing that as I said can affect
is the way nodes will report how
accurate they they will report their
performance and they can do this either
because they're just curious and they
just want for example to obtain some
privileged positions in the routing
structures allowing them
to see more of the data that people are
sending around and maybe using later on
for other things traffic analysis is one
one thing that people don't talk very
much about but actually it will it's
done and it's it's an issue or they have
other intentions now one thing that I
want to point out about this particular
system is that you will always have a
service because all these we started
with the cellular so which means that
clients will always have a will have at
least the cellular service because the
base station it's there for them so they
can get their service on the cellular
channel at the same time so so the
militias the demolitions account may not
necessarily be able to prevent the
service completely however you know it's
all a matter of perception so if you
manage to create the perception that the
system is
correctly and you managed to
use the trust that people having young
you actually achieved your goal so even
even if I think they can always get the
third
we are the changeling if you manage to
convince and the things are not working
in the purpose of having the app out
there then they're not reliable you
managed to create
so
and of course I didn't mention
authentication but most of the problems
in network protocol is that where they
start so people talk about complicating
the time but there is no nothing you can
build in terms of security services
before looking at authentication without
having authenticate
there is not much you can
so there are several things that we
looked at in
case you have is not only authenticating
participants that are part of the
network was in my league of network in
mind
energy constraints so the batter is art
thank you very much
so one of the interesting things with
the mindful grouting is that it's not
enough to have authentication of the
people in the network actually many
times you need to have authentication of
the path hop-by-hop so we look at things
like that and again we build on the fact
that this epic particular application
has a central point of trust which was
the base station also we look at how to
design a payment diverting mechanisms
that can prevent reloading and also can
deal with some type of a selfish
behavior where they want for example if
some some selfish knows they would
actually collude and they would like to
add other nodes in the network just to
be part and get the service and we also
look at the much stronger things like
how would you detect malicious behavior
in this particular context where
malicious behavior will be for example
selectively dropping off packets and as
I said this problem is actually much
it's less difficult than when you have a
completely ad-hoc network just because
you have this natural point of trust
which is the base station and because
you do have point-to-point communication
so multihop communications one of the
reason that it makes things very
difficult when you look at insiders is
because you do not trust that the data
really will make it just because you
have intermediate nodes so we took
advant we take advantage of the fact
that we do have a point to point
communication physical communication
which is the cellular just to see to
what to what degree how far can we push
this so things that we did we modify for
example in the previous protocol we have
this past reservation which means you
know adding and did it with adding nodes
I think flows when a node wants to
obtain a traffic so we modify that to
have it to have it a secure pass
reserved a reservation not only as I
said authentication it's a mess but
that's not the difficult problem but
there were things that we build on here
because the base station is really the
one that can see that the traffic indeed
was all because the bay station is the
point of trust note can report to
then the base station is the one that
can actually make decisions with rapport
with respect to of giving credit there
are other things that you have to deal
with just on one side for example we
said oh it's very good to have this
point to point channel but you cannot
send so much on you so if you every
every time you have some control
information you say I'm going to send it
to through the cellular link you
actually getting through it into other
products because you're going to have of
that becoming a bottleneck in your
system so one of the things that we look
at for example in terms of the the
payment we wanted to capture this on one
side the just the charge because you're
using the system we also wanted to
capture have some cost just because
people are initiating this protocol to
try to prevent some type of denial of
service and also we wanted to capture
this notion of crediting intermediate
nodes that actually do behave correctly
in the system and these three particular
things are covered it and we also had
some mechanism that actually week which
we could bog we could show exactly on
how much of the malicious or selfish
that want to add extra nodes we could
tolerate based on some parameters that
we adjust in the last component now
besides that one of the problems it
depends of course of your application
some people think that if you lose
packets is not a big deal but if you
would really like to look in the an
extreme adversary environment where you
have noticed that maliciously will drop
data the question is how can you route
around them and should you take them out
of the network or not and for example
here my approach is that in a network
like that the seller and the ad hoc
taking them completely down can actually
hurt you because you can partition your
network and as long as you can get them
to transfer some assuming that is not a
completely that they will drop all the
packets but selectively they will send
something you may want to keep them in
the network but just decrease
the way you the likelihood that you're
going to use them now another big issue
here is for example assuming that you
now you do not trust you trust only your
source and the destination how do you
know who's the bad guy well Alice says
that Bob is the one that is causing the
problem and bob says that alice is the
one causing the problem and actually we
know this from fundamental disability
systems results that you cannot have
agreement in this context so it turned
out that actually for the in the case of
this application we care much less about
who was the malicious we cared about the
fact that the link was bad so we
actually penalize both of them that was
our approach in this context to deal
with this difficult problem to say fine
all I care in the end is if the data
makes it or not now another thing that
we also did in the context of this
problem because I said we didn't want to
take the nose completely out of the
network what we did in this context we
actually tried to bound the amount of
data that we could lose on a particular
link and we had our mechanisms to that
assigned cost with each bit with each
particular link took into account
exactly this how do we reward them and
how do we penalize and such that over
time if over time they do send a
particular day delay and a certain
amount of traffic we consider them that
that's good enough to keep them in the
network as opposed of taking them
completely out because taking them
completely out also what what brings
into place is that when people start
blaming each other so that's a one of
the problems always with the blacklist
they start blaming each other there are
other issues that come into place in
this case because what we were doing
basically we were looking at just having
feedback back from the client that
indeed data make it so in a previous
work where for example we look at this
pure ad hoc we had a huge problem just
because the messages the probes and the
acknowledgement that sells always went
through the same path
as the regular data which means that if
you do not make them looking like
regular traffic and you can allow the
adversary to actually be able to
distinguish between the real between the
control which is the probing and
technologies and the data they can trick
you very easily and we had ways to deal
with that in that context of course cost
is not it I will not hide it it's
extremely expensive cryptography
protocols usually they come with a
certain costs in communications even
more but again here what we could do we
actually had some heuristics on one side
we could use the point-to-point channels
and then we use some heuristic such that
we would we could decrease the cost of
sending this feedback back to the base
station and these are some of the issues
that we looked at in this context now
switching gears a little bit what I
wanted to talk about is another problem
that I found very interesting and this
relates with the fact that today many
networks self-organizing networks they
rely to on some type of adaptivity
mechanism just to optimize whatever the
goal of that network is so in the case
of overlays for example many of them are
built to optimize bandwidth primarily
and latency a secondary and the way this
usually it is so far people look at it
at the positive aspects which is nice
you do their systems out there that can
really show you that you get very good
benefit by performing this type of
adaptivity at the same time once I am
looking at the decisions are actually n
systems if I take into account that
maybe one of them maybe will not behave
correctly and once I say one will not
behave the question would be why just
one because whatever the reason may make
one machine to compromise you cannot
assume that you're going to have in all
your network only one malicious
participant that will not behave
necessarily according to the protocol so
there are several attacks that can
happen and to analyze this problem
actually what the my student Aaron I
look at we picked on ESL
well why assume just because we had the
code available and we also we were
knowledgeable in how the system or so we
could actually go through the whole deal
and actually running experiments and
getting the real graph that shows that
attackers can cause problems by
exploiting conductivity so in the
context of multicast overlay the main
feature that we looked at is this fact
that the tree dynamically adapt to
maintain a certain application centric
metrics bandwidth primarily latency
roundtrip also it's another one that for
example esm looks like looks at and you
have you know the logical you in the
case of museum for example there are two
logical networks and one physical two
logical because besides the mighty
costly you actually have another network
that is doing the control messages with
respect to maintaining the membership of
the nodes that are part of the overlay
now the way this adaptivity works is the
based on two primary sources of
information one of them is a passive
observation of what the node perceives
to help from the source another one is
actually obtained from neighbors through
periodic probing so we call one
primarily the other one second V and
based on this matrix that every node as
I said one is from the source the other
one is periodic probing they actually
build every sampling period they will
build utility functions or there's three
supportive but there is some utility
function and based on that utility
function will make a decision if the
performance that is getting at that
point it's good enough if and if it's
good enough nothing happens if it's not
good enough then we'll make the decision
to change so the observation is that
actually it is very important to have
either an accurate reflection of the
network conditions in the way it is
reported by the probing nodes or that
you know that the information itself
it's correct
because if that is not the case then you
made up making decisions that you don't
want to so to give it one more detail is
actually the way it works in the case of
esm it's a more complex that's another
thing that we like it is because it has
many it uses many techniques to deal
with several projects that appear in the
context of adaptivity and in this case
like damping and / crowds and all that
so they they have done in these
techniques that can look at it so in
this case basically what actually
happens Indian is that you have a short
list that it's repaired and the utility
function is not the only one that is
taken into account but you have also
some randomization factor that besides
if you're doing the switch or not and
basically when we looked at it and all
the design we said you know this is not
built to withstand malicious but it
looks like actually has very nice
mechanism actually it may work it may be
possible that our attack will be would
not be successful just because as I said
there are these small engineering things
that actually can allow him to detect
least that's what we thought some of
this malicious behavior so before going
to the attack we look at what will be
things that can go wrong assuming that I
can make the network to adapt in a way
that the adversary controls that
particular adaptation so one of the
things with with the trees the trees are
very on one side they're very good in
terms of performance but when you look
at a malicious environment they're
actually pretty bad and the reason is
because you know once you get one of
those adversaries to control a
particular node in the tree in the
hiring the tree the more power he has
and unfortunately one of the things that
for example the attacker could do and we
were managed to create this behavior is
by consistently lying about the metrics
that you perceived since he went higher
in the tree so he went higher and higher
and higher of course he cannot say
getting
so we check that and that that that work
usually in a simple changes of now
definitely he that was detected he
couldn't say that he gets more than the
source but still could get higher in the
in the tree and what that allows it is
to actually control as I said
significant traffic what he decides to
do afterwards it's really his decision
now another thing that can go wrong in
this relates this is also very
interesting attack this relates more
with freeloading but also with this
plamen of nodes is because the node is
inside one thing that he can do he can
actually make notes to to detach from a
particular node either by lying or by
filling up it's very easy to fill up the
pipe just that particular link and
because the attack the amount of traffic
actually what we showed is that you have
to send very little traffic just to fill
up that particular Oh God so because
because the amount of traffic that he
needs to send to do that is very small
that's one of the problem with detection
so attacks that actually send lots of
traffic they're easy to detect if you
send very little is much more difficult
and you know you know the attack with
the TCP is one of the first that
actually showed that once you you can
create small birds for very short time
exactly when the system is supposed to
adapt then it's more much more difficult
to detect so this was another thing that
that we look we looked at now finally it
may look that this is not a big deal but
the adaptation itself can create
instability and maybe now is the time to
put to work I took lots of control serum
undergraduate degree was in engineering
so all those control theory classes I
think that now they maybe I can make
good use of them so instability it's a
big issue that happens also can come up
in many distributed systems where you
want to maintain some type of for
example membership and people just cup
you know coming and living coming and
leaving coming and leaving they can
create lots of instability so this was
the third thing that we identified it
can be a big issue so what we did in the
beginning we just look at the system you
know in its deployment we took esm we
got a bunch of nodes on Planet lab and
we said let's take only one attacker but
what I what we want first show that we
can move it up in the tree and once I
move it in the tree just to show how
much control he will help over the
network just do dropping on that just
lets drop data on that particular node
and see what happens if the system via
and 12b the surprise the system actually
did not react the for 20 minutes we
measure Lisa we run it for 90 minutes
for 20 minutes nothing happened which if
you think about the way for example the
system was deployed primarily in
conferences at Oak is 25 minutes so if
you out of the 25 you don't get 20
probably it wasn't a good use of your
time another thing that we also looked
at when we looked at what type of
instability is caused in the tree how
many changes do actually you start
seeing and we were also very surprised
to see how many how many changes in the
tree we see just because you have one
malicious node that consistently keeps
telling that I have this high bandwidth
I have this small agency I have the way
they cannot affect the rtt in both
direction right because the rtt they can
never make it better they can always
make it worse as the post of the others
where they are the ones issuing the
information anyway so then we said okay
let's get more of them and see what can
go wrong and of course this proved what
is something that as I said it's a very
intuitive that the tree is not the right
structure to do this but see the problem
is that if you want performance you
usually people go with the tree and they
think about the security afterwards and
it turns out that the tree is not the
right structure for this now what we
what we oh this is an under attack that
when I was mentioning before about
detaching the nodes
this is actually where the fact that you
the physical the way the physical
connectivity maps the logical one was
exploited by the node actually to make
by the malicious node to make a note
detach so this is this is very detached
from the source so this is actually very
bad because the note C was connected to
the source and how better than that you
think you're going to do that being
connected to the source and we actually
make it connect three hops later and we
didn't have to send lots of traffic now
looking at the big problem is I said the
two primary source of information and if
you really want to see what what are the
things that you can deal with what you
do with what you can do you have the
adaptation process which is just
information that comes into the node
that makes the decision maybe that maybe
some of the best decisions you can
detect them like for example dropping of
data if indeed is something that it's
observable you may detect but if the
goal of this particular attack is for
example ultimately traffic analysis you
have some colluding adversaries how do
you know you're never going to know what
happened if you do not know that that
this particular nodes really do in an
unfair playing an unfair game actually
see lots of the traffic in the network
so we have the detection that sometimes
it may work for some attacks but not for
all of them of course you have to have
some type of response what do you do
assuming that you do detect why
terminations what would you do with them
and overall I think it's always good to
look at how do you improve stability so
these are all big issues and we look at
all of them but what I wanted to show
it's some things that you can do to
prevent bed adaptations in the sense
that have some smarter choices give the
note that makes adaptation some smarter
choices in terms of the data that you
make available for them so the first
thing that I want to mention is that
when you are dealing with malicious
adversaries you cannot always solve the
problem so there are there there are
cases in which there is no way you're
going to solve the problem
simple case well if your attack militias
are majority what do you think you're
going there is nothing that you can
achieve right so there are some
assumptions the order conditions under
which you can get some some type of
solutions but even there depending even
there if you can get some solution in
general most of them are extremely
expensive so the only way you can cut
some of the cost is really by tailoring
your particular we know that we like
everything to be very general but
because of the cost the only way you can
get this to be less prohibited by any
tailoring on the looking at the nature
of the application and the problem that
you're solving so when you cannot do you
go ahead sorry no because so that's so
that's what's the attacker screws up
your performance because he wants you to
take with that
it's another way so you are technically
doing better because you're avoiding the
adversaries by all violence by academic
that's not a bad at invasion even though
it was it still it's not about
adaptation to improve your lock life
defending the impact
no I think that what what you're saying
is maybe that by adapting you actually
get less performance then you think the
time considering that good is that what
you're saying say ma my goal is to get
you to that's why the way I do that is
by making it making giving you thermal
performance when you're attached through
and giving you and stopping by exactly
you're not actually is not giving its
lying yeah so suppose I do that not with
wine but with suppose I actually make it
worse than you're attached to the parent
then when you're not hmm is it
considered a bad adaptation so first of
all that's a different type of attack
because that it's denial of service that
the reason that I do not consider an
order I don't look at denial of services
because I think that you can detect it
with other mechanisms what I look is
that things that if the nature of the
information is not the quantity of it
but that can be an example but denial of
service I think you have different
methods to deal with it and almost any
system that I look at they they are
susceptible to that you know if I go
back to the wireless thing i can tell
you you know that we have the best
protocols in the world and you can just
come up and you just jump the channel i
I know a panasonic phone that when we
had that in the lab nothing worked
whatever best routing we have there so i
think the denial of service its are
different but you're right that can
cause problems now to go back to this
one thing that i want to mention is that
i was talking about the nature of the
information and exploiting
application-specific semantics because
otherwise you cannot know if that is
good or bad there are cases in which you
can never know if the information is
correct is for example if you always
have one source of information and there
is no way you can collaborate
corroborate that then you're in big
trouble in fact most of the disability
system protocol the way that they deal
with this they say well we assuming have
somebody that is correct we keep sending
to everybody we learn what everybody
knows and we do some voting on it but
the assumption is that everybody has the
information if you have one one person
generating that there is not much you
can do however one of the things that we
could exploit in this context which I
found interesting is the fact that what
you can look at the attacker is that
consistency right so if is not
consistent in terms of the nature of the
information maybe you can make his life
difficult in the sense that you have to
make him to do a better job at life
when he's building the key for the
information that he's disseminating so
what are things that consistency that we
looked at one of them is remember if I
have appearance around me right and I do
have a mapping of the physical and the
logical network if I know this type of
mapping you know and you're here then
you're telling you to get these great
performance and all these other nodes
around they telling me they are telling
me that this is not the case maybe I can
infer something that shows me there is
some inconsistency going on another
thing that also was interesting in this
case is the fact that there are several
metrics that are taken into
consideration and actually they are not
independent there is some relation
between them so you you cannot tell me
you know that you have a great bandwidth
and the latency is not somehow related
with that or the rtt with the latency so
this is another thing that we thought
about exploiting the fact that the
metrics that are reported you have to to
present them to me in a consistent
matter if because they are not
independent and the last one which is
the most natural and most of the systems
do is looking at behavior over time and
that that's the most easiest to look at
so what we actually wanted to have with
some method that will not require any
additional communication overhead and
what we look at how can we do outlier
detection on this data that it's
reported exactly exploiting these
consistency issues that i talked about
primarily the one with relation to the
space to the time and the other one
related with the space and in the
context of the space exploiting the fact
that there is the dependency between the
variables reported and Aaron had a lot
of experience in intrusion detection and
he thought that this particular distance
it's a very good match for our problem
that we were trying to solve exactly
because of the fact monomial distant
exactly because of the fact that it
captures this dependency that exists
between the feature features that we are
examining and we are making the
adaptation based on so what we did we
basically build the two of two methods
one that I said look at the spatial so
by spatial what I mean how other peers
are
reporting what's going on in Iran and
also what is the relation between the
variables reported by each particular
node so we call this patient the other
one that we looked at was the books oh
the other one that we look at is the
tempera which was how it behaves over
past and of course we had some problems
just to give you one quick thing you
know the difference between what you put
on the paper and when you're running in
the lab so one of the things that for
instance we run into which are things
that are specific to this type of
systems is what happens if there is no
variance so well this is one particular
case in which you have to decide what
you do we run it on landed up a panel of
lots of variants everything works fine
we have some other problem we move it in
a cluster no variance so these are all
type of things that showed up you know
in real deployments and we had to come
up with some heuristics with respect to
how to address and how to bootstrap the
system in the first place and in the
second one what will we do in that
particular case now another thing that
and we had a way of combining this
together just to have a method in which
this will be integrated in the utility
function what we did we run again we
start writing bunch of experiments with
the new method looking both of the
temporal and spatial and they definitely
show that they can they can they can
address the big outliers now one thing
that we didn't do here again we didn't
look at what will have colluding so this
is just the first step of how would I
deal even with the simplest problem just
to take out this big outliers so in this
case we didn't look at colluding but
another thing that was surprising for us
is by just integrating just by making
the data to reflect or to avoid this
very big changes we actually improve the
stability over all of the system and we
always plot bandwidth so actually what
happened is although with these less
changes the band is never went the each
node never reported the band is going
down which means that there were
unnecessary changes that the system was
doing and we this is something that we
so we continue working on and we'd like
to take this to looking at also it
colluding yes
yeah yeah sorry so I know what you mean
that's why you have to combine this with
some response mechanism you over time
you can make this you can make the the
distance of the other mechanism itself
particularly the temporal one which is
something that we ran into this this is
a problem with all this type of system
yes you're right that's why you one of
the thing that is very important is how
would you react and another thing that
we actually do in combination with this
we actually look also at global context
because we do have the source and we
also look at the mapping so the global
for example global with global context
can allow us is to combine these with
information between the nodes and
looking at the whole path so we can we
can build in terms of the reputation of
the nodes also of looking at what's
going on over the passion with everybody
is saying just to have more how can i
pitted basically increase or decrease
the reputation of nodes by using several
sources of information but one thing
about this what I want to point out is
that basically we did not add any
communication overhead in the system all
we did is just improving this taking out
at least the big outliers okay and I
want to be on time so just to summarize
it's not enough to look on yet the fault
tolerance aspects of the protocols
without putting security because they
actually I have even more examples of
how the moment you put security in to
the system it may change completely or
design some people will just go and say
it well you want to do business
resilient maybe the tree is not good
just give up the tree why not send five
packet five copies that's what some
people propose right you go into
multipath but that change is really the
initial design and goal of the system
now in terms of the security i think
that although it's very important you
should never add security such as you
make the unattractive for the strip for
the clients because they're not going to
use it there's many
many examples in that aspect so one way
I can see always it how can you go about
it you know you in terms of research we
are always trying to look at the
stronger thing which usually come with
some cost but when you are looking at
practical applications the critical
aspects are the nature of the
application and the environment actually
the environment is the one that triggers
most of the security concerns that you
have in the same application you develop
into different environments and you may
have different security requirements and
there's some techniques that I think
they can be incorporated in the mansion
because you're going to have similar
problems that the ones that I described
and just to finish things that we are
working on right now so for example we
are looking at what our security
problems in geographical routing on the
overlays we I look up with very basic
security services if you want to
integrate very simple things like you
management how does that actually affect
the performance of your system in terms
of first traffic in terms of even how
would you do the reliable dissemination
because these are very particular
control messages all you need is to lose
some key in the beginning and you
actually are not going to be able to
decrypt the information afterwards I was
mentioning the global information in the
mapping between the physical topology
and the the logical network and finally
we are also as I said I'm looking at
collaborative applications in the
context of mentioned there's three
things that they're now on the table 1
is distributed infrastructure access the
other one is how to do a secure
multicast in a many-to-many environment
because that's what people want to do
they want to do chat and the last one is
how would you do available information
access because there are business or the
increase the robustness at least allows
me allows you to think about it in the
context of ad hoc I you know or if you
could talk it was or if we could realign
information that was good enough but
having real high available system I
think would have been more difficult and
that's it and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much